donovan congrats what a ball game
i mean that last possession the clippers
had a chance to tie this thing up you
guys didn't have a chance to communicate
defensively what did you see on that
possession
um you scrambled on the fly you know i
think the best thing we
we just were instinctive you know rudy
made a hell of a play that's why his
defensive play of the year
you know we did a great job of that
and you're getting a lot of mvp chance
right now donovan but the turnaround in
this game started in that third quarter
the first
two and a half minutes you scored 10
straight points
what was your focus at that point oh man
i let my team down the first half on
both ends of the floor
you know i let reggie and luke kind of
get hot they were kicking my ass a
little bit you know i came in the locker
room i wasn't making the right reads in
the first half so i said you know what
guys
it's all me you know at the end of the
day it's on me and you know i had to go
out there and just set the tone and we
did our thing
now we saw dwyane wade sitting over
there you guys were chatting all night
long this was a wild game
did he help you with any advice to get
through this one yeah just things that
he saw
throughout the game and you know it's
great to have you know someone i call my
brother you know seeing courtside
being part of this organization just
trying to help me out and find ways to
improve
and not just with myself but finding
ways with the team and you know i think
that's the biggest thing and just
you know i'm grateful that he's able to
do that not a lot of guys do that you
know and be able to do it especially
live action in the playoff game but
you know it was great when you take a
look at the first half to the second
half
what's the takeaway heading into game
two they gotta play hard
you know they're they're a talented team
you know at the end of the day we did
some things wrong they did some things
wrong and we're going to go ahead and
adjust foot
they're talented we got to go out there
be ready to compete every single game
and every single second
can't let our foot off the gas and
credit to them they came out it's going
to be a dogfight game too
and we gotta be ready thank you
appreciate it thank you so much
all right rebecca thank you so much
donovan mitchell with a tremendous
performance
greg a hot topic of conversation will be
the fact that the clippers did have a
timeout remaining
and they elected to play it out on that
final possession ended up in scramble
mode
yeah and you know what i have no problem
with it for a couple reasons one
a lot of times when you've got the
veteran experience
and talent that they have you don't want
to allow a great defensive team an
opportunity
to then go and break down how they want
to defend it you just have to credit
utah for being better
they were very disciplined in that last
possession and didn't allow for a good
look and
listen they gave themselves a chance did
the clippers in a game where it looked
like he was going to get away from him
but they battled unfortunately couldn't
get it over the hump and they'll have to
try to do it in game two
our final score tonight